as someone has been so open about their
own health journey what does being your
best self look like to you as you
continue down this road
my best self is like definitely someone
who's living a healthy lifestyle
which is both like physically and
mentally and so i'm always kind of
working to to improve things
there and then
um
like working hard but playing hard as
well
so like in senior year we shot it in
atlanta oh it was hot and uh but we
worked our asses off but then we also
had the best fun like just going to the
movies or um
going for walks and going to the park
and and things in our breaks that were
like really like like special to me
i had the hot boyfriend
and all that was left was prom queen
[Applause]
[Music]
i think there's been a mistake and i've
been put in the wrong room dr johnson to
the third floor the cheerleader just
woke up you brought me back girl
oh yeah that's that's our aim because
this movie works for like kids who are
currently kids and then kids who like
kids in the 90s 2000s
got a lot of nostalgia in this film
there's so many moments that i was like
feeling very nostalgic as you put it but
what was it like for you how much fun
did you have not only going back to high
school but like reliving the early odds
what a great era oh i just had the best
fun like the but the first time i put on
those low rise jeans
and like and like the outfit that
britney spears wears in the crazy video
i was like oh i don't like oh did i used
to wear clothes like this yeah right um
but i really liked i had one hairstyle
where i had all these little butterfly
clips and then i put like glitter roll
on all over me and i was like really
feeling myself
um in in that outfit but it was really
fun to go back and just also listen to
all that pop music
from from back then that's in the film
and it was just like it was yeah it was
so much fun um and also just reliving
highs like going back to high school
i've had so many dreams
where that's happened and then i'm like
now it's just like my dream where i go
back to high school
but maybe it's part reality because i
feel like some things from that era
they're coming back you know fashion
wise music wise but speaking of music i
love that the movie ended with that
bewitched song c'est la vie it's like
how cute is that song it's so cute i'm
like oh my god i still remember all the
words to it that's what's so crazy about
it oh yeah but i want to talk to you
about recreating the you drive me crazy
video i mean why was britney like the
perfect song choice for that scene
well like we had to get britney's
permission and i was really nervous
about um oh my gosh i hope she she knows
like we're paying homage to her
uh with this and and it was really
awesome that
that she did give permission to do it
and i just thought um there were some
britney songs that we'd already done in
like pitch perfect
and stuff but crazy uh was just such a
cool song and such an iconic video clip
where they're like dancing and uh
um
and i just
i just thought that would be really cool
to recreate and we recreated that exact
set uh and did it and what was weird is
like
i didn't really like
practice that much just when i shot it i
tried to just
like channel britney
and then really um our director alex
hardcastle was like
oh my god you were like so britney in
certain takes i like really just i
believed i was her in in the thing
and it comes off like really funny i
think
no but you're you're so in it and like
you guys really did a good job of
recreating that even when it cut to you
as like the what is it like the the
diner server
yeah oh i was like
yeah and danny that was our last day of
shooting and it was like 110 degrees in
atlanta and uh but you know once they
pump that britney music i was just like
loving it i wanted to give it my all she
has that power right you just are
overcome with like rip rip i love it
yeah um now obviously in this movie your
character awakes from a 20-year coma to
relive their senior year if you could do
a do-over of anything from high school
what would it be
probably uh my hair choices
somehow i had bangs but like they're not
like normal bangs like now they were
only like an inch long
like a super short fringe and i was like
uh
um also like i was really feral in in
high school and it didn't really have
any fashion sense or i really didn't
care i went to an all girls school we
didn't really
care what we looked like um so i would
probably
learn something about uh about makeup
like my character doesn't make up
tutorials in the film and i would
probably learn something about
presenting myself nicely i was more
concerned about like getting top marks
and getting into law school which worked
you know worked out great but um
in hindsight every time i look back at
pictures of me i was like what was i
thinking like i looked shocking
you did share that you were also a bit
of a prankster in high school is it true
that you locked a teacher in a cupboard
yeah i did i locked a mean english
teacher in a cupboard also they deserved
it uh yeah
i mean it was probably a bit harsh
because she cried when she was locked in
the cupboard
like four hours um
but and and then one time like i would i
would break into the canteen do you guys
have school canteens that sell the food
the cafeterias yes like um and
and then i so i would do some naughty
things organize the escapes from the
boarding house where i lived there was a
boys school like across the river and
like we would escape out
um and so i would do like cheeky things
one cheeky prank i did to the teachers
is i smoking was very like banned at our
school was like the worst thing he could
do
so i um i stood in the parking lot
pretending to smoke it wasn't a real
cigarette it was like one of those fake
ones
um and then the teachers got all angry
and said we're gonna expel you and i'm
like you can't it's not a real cigarette
and then
so just cheeky little things like that
so you're a bit mischievous huh even
though you were also getting good marks
yeah i was a good student so they could
never expel me that's the way to do it
it's all about balance right yeah
you know what i loved about this movie
though is that you know that message the
takeaway about uh living authentically
and just trying to be the best version
of yourself i mean how does it feel to
be part of a film that really speaks to
how we perceive each other and this
whole idea of like fitting in especially
when you're young in high school
yeah well what uh what i really loved
about this film in this cast is like
it's so inclusive
um in all areas and and and the message
of the film that my character learns is
like firstly like high school doesn't
define you and also like to just be your
real self like don't try to be somebody
else to to fit in
um oh wait and what was the second part
of your question just decide like you
know the fact that they're really
showing us how you don't need to fit in
it's like be unique because that's
what's special outside of it well my
character has a quote in the film like
why fit in when you can stand out
exactly and i really really like that my
friend brandon scott jones wrote that
who is on ghost is one of the believing
ghosts he is a very funny writer and but
also poignant and that line is like yeah
why would you want to fit in when you
can stand out and in australia like
sadly a lot of us are taught like you
have to just be normal and don't don't
stand out in any way
uh i was someone who was different and i
wanted to go out into the world and
crush it and so i i was different and
unique and i had to learn to to embrace
that about myself and so i hope
especially the young people watching um
they can they can get a really nice
[Music]
you